ja schon tag herr maas sogar gestern
noch bei den corona verhandlungen aber
wir wollen demnächst wir wollen zunächst
darüber sprechen was an der polnische
spieler russischen grenze passiert und
immer noch passieren kann in den
nächsten wochen wir haben gerade gehört
was der polnische premier gesagt hat er
sagt es könnten millionen menschen nach
deutschland kommen wenn man jetzt nicht
aufpasst wenn man dort eben nichts tut
wie haben sie diese aussagen waren also
im moment haben wir an der polnisch
spiele russischen grenze ist mit einigen
tausend menschen zu tun das ist schlimm
genug denn deren situation ist wirklich
schrecklich
im grunde geht es aber um die frage weil
es wird immer vom schutz der
aussengrenzen gesprochen es geht darum
wie dieser schutz organisiert wird und
ich glaube die voraussetzung für eine
erfolgreiche zuwanderungspolitik ist
eine geordnete zur zuwanderungspolitik
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass an den
grenzen auch kontrolliert wird das ist
auch einrichtungen gibt die dazu führen
dass man nicht überall über die grenze
kommen kann sonst verlieren wir den
überblick und die kontrolle über die
zuwanderung und deshalb ist es wichtig
wenn die außengrenzen europas geschützt
werden dann ist nichts hornist sind
mauern trainermarkt mauern oder
stacheldraht oder zäune aber wenn
diejenigen die kommen an bestimmten
stellen nach europa gelassen werden und
zwar so dass sie auch registriert werden
können dass wir wissen wie viele kommen
dass wir wissen woher sie kommen dass
sie auch vernünftig verteilt werden
können das ist schon eine voraussetzung
und das hat durchaus auch etwas damit zu
tun dass man grenzübergänge braucht über
die dann die zuwanderung geschieht und
das ist nicht überall nur über die grüne
grenze gehen also helfen bauern in dem
konkreten fall also wir brauchen ob das
mauern sind glaube ich nicht unbedingt
wir wollen auch nicht europa ein mauern
aber wer geordnete zuwanderung will der
muss auch dafür sorgen dass an der
grenze nicht jeder kommen kann wie er
will sie sprechen die thematik kann
jeder kommen kann wie er will jetzt gibt
es eine debatte darüber ob die
flüchtlinge die momentan an der grenze
sind rund zwei bis dreitausend ob die
nach deutschland gelassen werden sollte
man hört dass ein thema gewesen sein in
dem telefonat zwischen herrn lukas
schenk und der kanzlerin was ist ihre
meinung sollte deutschland flüchtlinge
aufnehmen also erstmal muss man ja sagen
dass wir schon fast 10.000 aufgenommen
haben die über diesen weg nach polen
gekommen sind und über polen nach
deutschland weitergereist diese menschen
sind in deutschland aufgenommen werden
werden die ganz normalen geordneten
verfahren verlauf es ist also nicht so
dass wir auch aus diesem grenzkonflikt
zwischen polen und bella wo ist noch
keine menschen aufgenommen hätten die
frage ist was mit geschieht mit denen
die da sind und da ist das was wir auch
wir wollen keine bilaterale lösung
zwischen deutschland und belarus oder
wie immer sondern wir wollen eine
europäische
montag saßen die außenminister europas
zusammen und wir sind uns einig dass wir
die menschen zurück führen sollen und
müssen in die länder aus denen sie
kommen denn alles andere würde bedeuten
dass lukaschenko gewonnen hat das ist
eine aufnahme von flüchtlingen in
deutschland wir haben schon flüchtlinge
aufgenommen aber die die sich dort im
grenzgebiet noch aufhalten wollen wir
gemeinsam jetzt erst einmal humanitär
versorgen das rote kreuz ist
mittlerweile da die menschen werden da
weg gebracht von der grenze aber sie
sollen zurückgeführt werden in ihre
herkunftsländer damit nicht der eindruck
entsteht dass lukaschenko mit seinem
wirklich menschenunwürdigen spiel auch
noch gewonnen hat und das muss jeder
wissen er darf sich nicht darauf
einlassen weil ansonsten wird es neue
zuführung geben und es werden menschen
glauben dass man da hin kommen muss weil
man am schluss doch nach deutschland
kommt oder nach europa und deshalb ist
es wichtig jetzt sehr alle humanitären
leistungen zu organisieren das geschieht
aber die menschen müssen zurückgebracht
werden in ihre herkunftsländer also hat
der polnische premier recht wenn er
warnt wenn man jetzt ein paar tausend
aufnimmt das dann hunderttausende
vielleicht millionen kommen könnten am
ende ja ich glaube vor allen dingen geht
es jetzt darum zu zeigen dass luca
schenke uns nicht erpressen kann aber
lasst uns mal bei dem zitat bleiben also
das hat ja der polnische premier gesagt
er sagt wenn man jetzt ein paar tausend
aufnimmt dann passiert genau das was
auch sie angesprochen haben nämlich dann
denken die menschen sie können wieder
nach europa nach deutschland dann
wiederholt sich 2015 und noch mehr
menschen würden kommen also wir haben
nicht die situation für 2015 ist sind
hunderttausende auf dem weg nach europa
wir nehmen aber weiter jeden monat
tausende menschen auf die zu uns kommen
die asyl beantragen die einen
flüchtlingsstatus bekommen das muss nur
geordnet über die bühne gehen und in
einer billa russisch polnischen grenze
da geht es um einen erpressungsversuch
eines verbrecherischen
diktators und dem darf man nicht
nachgeben dass wir eine große humanitäre
verantwortung haben bei den ganzen
flucht bewegungen die es auf der welt
gibt das ist so und das wird auch immer
so bleiben und ehrlich gesagt es gibt
kein land in europa das seit 2015 so
viele menschen aufgenommen hat wie
deutschland wir haben da kein
nachholspielen 2015 an da hat der
polnische premier gesagt angela merkel
habe da völlig versagt die regierung
habe völlig versagt weil man eben so
viele menschen aufgenommen habe hat er
recht er hat unrecht und ehrlich gesagt
ich bin in den letzten vier jahren viel
in der welt herumgekommen
ich habe gesehen dass es ein hohes
ansehen deutschlands gibt und dass die
art und weise wie wir mit flüchtlingen
umgehen und umgegangen sind auch 2015
hat deutschlands ansehen noch einmal
deutlich erhöht es gibt viele in den
unterschiedlichsten regionen dieser welt
die das gesehen haben die das
respektieren und die der auffassung sind
dass deutschland richtig gehandelt hat
flüchtlinge großes thema auch bei der
frage was jetzt in afghanistan passiert
erstmals haben diplomaten mit den
taliban verhandelt was ist dabei
rausgekommen
wir haben noch einmal ganz deutlich erst
einmal unsere grundsätzlichen
politischen erwartungen geäußert das ist
eine inklusive regierung gibt es die
menschenrechte eingehalten werden wir
haben aber auch damit signalisiert wir
sind bereit miteinander zu sprechen wir
haben auch die erwartung dass die
ortskräfte die nach wie vor noch in
afghanistan sind nicht von der
provisorischen afghanischen regierung
von den taliban daran gehindert werden
also das wollen wir organisieren und
dafür brauchen wir auch die taliban ganz
einfach das geht anders wenn ich das
sagen die diplomaten sehen wie wir das
so mit den taliban am tisch zu sitzen
und zu fahren na ja das ist schon
speziell weil die
in afghanistan ist ja ein schwieriges
thema und das sind nicht diejenigen die
wir uns das gewünscht haben als
gesprächspartner aber diplomaten müssen
realitäten auch anerkennen und das tun
wir realitäten anerkennen einmal ganz
kurz noch mal zurück zum polnischen
premier der hat gesagt es braucht einen
stopp von nord stream 2 in richtung
putin und darüber wolle auch mit olaf
scholz sprechen hat das chancen
also er sollte dann mal mit ihm darüber
sprechen
nord stream 2 ist ein thema das uns
jetzt schon jahre verfolgt dieses
projekt ist kurz vor der fertigstellung
es ist jetzt eine weisung
ungebunden eine unabhängige behörde am
zug die bundesnetzagentur die im öl
bringt nochmal in den letzten tagen klar
entschieden hat dass das verfahren nicht
so einfach über die bühne geht das auch
die ukraine ein anhörungsrecht bekommt
dass die
regelungen der europäischen union
eingehalten werden müssen vom betreiber
unter sind sie bisher noch nicht und das
ist eine entscheidung auf die die
politik keinen einfluss mehr nehmen wird
herr maas wir müssen über das thema des
tages oder das thema der nächsten wochen
sprechen sie war gestern dabei bei der
korona schalte haben sie in dieser
wiederholt sich alles was vor anderthalb
jahren passiert ist genau
bedauerlicherweise hatte ich das schon
öfter in den letzten anderthalb jahren
aber das hilft ja nichts die situation
ist dramatisch und das sind sich alle
einig gewesen und ich bin auch froh dass
das einigermaßen im konsens da über die
bühne gegangen ist dass wir reagieren
müssen auf die situation die wir jetzt
haben das ist ja jetzt auch gestern auf
den weg gebracht wurden mit 3g 2g
steigen sie dann noch durch was jetzt wo
gilt also wo 2g 3g 2g plus na ja also
wir haben das ja mit vorbereitet und
insofern
glaube ich es ist nicht so ganz einfach
weil es viele unterschiedliche
regelungen gibt warum macht man nicht
eine einheitliche und ja weil es einfach
unterschiedliche situationen gibt und
nicht jede regel in der situation
unbedingt die passende ist also so viel
flexibilität braucht man ansonsten will
man immer viel und mehr flexibilität wir
müssen halt regeln schaffen die auch
etwas zur besserung beitragen und wenn
das immer überall die gleiche ist dann
ist das nicht unbedingt gewährleistet
deshalb muss man auch unterschiedliche
regelungen erlassen können es wird jeder
sich auch darüber erkundigen müssen wie
diese regeln sind aber ich glaube wir
haben alle eine verantwortung wenn es um
die bekämpfung des virus geht sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen damit wir auch sehr
bei die richtigen das tun was jetzt
richtig und wichtig ist und dazu so
dafür zu sorgen dass diese schrecklichen
zahlen wir noch und gleichzeitig gibt es
eine große frustration in der
bevölkerung weil viele politiker vieles
versprochen haben der
gesundheitsminister hat gesagt in fliegt
wird niemals kommen jetzt kommt eine
teil im pflicht auch in ihrer partei bei
der fdp wurden lockt bei uns
ausgeschlossen jetzt hat man das gefühl
ob tanz konnten dann in den nächsten
wochen kommen verstehen sie das wenn
bürger sagen wir glauben den politikern
eigentlich gar nichts mehr bei corona
also ich verstehe dass es unmut gibt und
das ist ehrlich gesagt also man ist ja
selber auch
wenn man das sieht es gibt ständig immer
wieder eine neue welle das ist natürlich
schwierig und natürlich ist es so dass
in der politik dann auch jeweils
reagiert werden muss aber es ist ja auch
nicht so dass es eine diskussion darüber
gebe dass es wieder eine umfassende
lockdown es gibt so wie das jetzt zum
beispiel ab montag in österreich ist er
da der fall ist es wird es in
deutschland nicht geben da schließen sie
ja das ist auch dafür gibt es auch keine
rechtliche grundlage mehr es gibt
regelungen die unterscheiden zwischen
geimpften und ungeimpften aber das ist
auch nicht notwendig muss man erklären
hatten lockdown verhängt plus
impfpflicht muss man sich am ende für
eins von beiden in deutschland
entscheiden oder wird beides nicht kommt
also es wird beides nicht kommen es wird
kein lockdown geben also keinen so wie
wir ihn kennen aus der vergangenheit ich
glaube dass das auch rechtlich gar nicht
mehr möglich ist wenn fast 70 prozent
der menschen geimpft sind für die kann
es keinen lockdown geben österreich geht
ja auch ja irgendwas nicht alles was in
österreich geht muss auch in deutschland
gehen muss auch nicht unbedingt sinnvoll
seien die zahlen in österreich sind
übrigens noch viel schrecklicher als die
in deutschland was mit dem gericht für
alle die wird es nicht geben es in
deutschland keine impfpflicht für alle
es wird eine impfpflicht geben für
bestimmte berufsgruppen und das halte
ich auch für richtig aber kann es sein
dass am 9 dezember wenn die nächste mpk
kommt dass wir dann über einen lock down
und impfpflicht für alle sprechen
schließen sie das weiter aus also
grundsätzlich fragen mit schließen sie
aus beantworte ich nicht gerade haben
sie ja schon ja gesagt ja ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass das nicht kommen es
gibt auch die rechtliche grundlage nicht
mehr dafür allgemeine lockdown zu
verhängen aber man muss ganz klar sagen
menschen von denen ein höheres
infektionsrisiko ausgeht nämlich
ungeimpfte die müssen sich gefallen
lassen dass sie anders behandelt werden
als solche die kämpfte was ist mit der
impfpflicht für alle warum wird die in
deutschland auf keinen fall kommen weil
wir es nicht für notwendig halten weil
wir es auch und aus
verfassungsrechtlichen gesichtspunkten
für schwierigkeiten und deshalb mit dem
was wir beschlossen haben 3g am
arbeitsplatz zb aber auch zweig in
anderen einrichtungen in restaurants und
so weiter halte ich für geeignet und ich
halte es nicht für notwendig eine
allgemeine impfpflicht in deutschland zu
verhängen mit dem was jetzt beschlossen
worden ist wird man stück für stück des
virus weiter wieder zurückdrängen können
sie hat außenminister wenn sie auf das
reisen schauen was uns dann den nächsten
wochen monaten
passieren kann noch in europa und der
welt rechnen sie damit dass wieder
grenzen geschlossen werden nein das
glaube ich nicht weil auch in vielen
anderen ländern auch die anzahl der
geimpften deutlich höher ist als noch
vor einem jahr
wenn man nicht geimpft ist wird man
weiter einschränkungen haben es gibt
länder da kommt man um geimpft gar nicht
mehr rein die und auch die
quarantänebestimmungen sind für die
ungeimpften andere als für geimpfte das
heißt also wer reisen will und wer spaß
haben will bei seinen reisen da sollte
sich vorher impfen lassen ansonsten
könnte es glaube ich kompliziert werden
gehen sie davon aus dass es in diesem
jahr zum beispiel skiurlaub geben wird
oder wird das klassische
tourismusgeschäft wie vor allem jahr so
nicht stattfinden also wenn ich mir mal
die orte anschauen wo man skifahren
gehen kann also zum beispiel in
österreich bei den zeit also die
instanzen über 1000 teilweise in den
skigebieten
unabhängig ob das dort erlaubt sein wird
weiß ich nicht ob es eine gute idee ist
in so einer situation an einem solchen
ort seinen urlaub zu verbringen wird es
reisewarnung geben
wir haben ja regeln also dort wo hoch
incidents gebiete ausgewiesen worden
sind sowie das ja auch für österreich
zum beispiel der fall gewesen ist an den
werden wir nichts ändern wir werden nur
reagieren auf die zahlen
was bedeutet das dann für menschen die
zum beispiel schon einen urlaub gebucht
haben in der region skiurlaub den den
man dort verbringen will wenn die
inzidenz so ansteigen dass ein gebiet
als risikogebiet ausgerufen wird dann
hat man auch ganz andere möglichkeiten
von der reise wieder zurückzutreten
aber ich glaube dass da wir ja
mittlerweile so lange mit dem thema
beschäftigt sind die leute sich schon
gut anschauen wo sie hin reisen und wann
sie eine reise buchen mittlerweile haben
viele reiseveranstalter für die das
wirklich schwierig ist sich aber auch
darauf eingestellt und möglichkeiten
geschaffen wenn ein land zum zum
risikogebiet ausgewiesen worden ist dann
auch zu entspricht entsprechend zu
reagieren und den kunden zu ermöglichen
von der reise zurückzutreten weil
ansonsten ja kaum noch einer eine reise
buchen wird weil er weiß wenn ich in die
situation bekommen komme aber nicht mehr
aus meinem reise vertrag herauskomme
dann brauche ich lieber gar nicht mehr
also insofern wenn sie eine buchen für
den winter oder haben sie gesagt sie
bleiben so aus es bleibt zu hause
abschließend herr maas noch sind sie
außenminister rechnen sie damit dass sie
außenminister bleiben oder ein anderes
ministeramt wechseln unter olaf scholz
in diesen tagen rechne ich mit gar
nichts wer wird das außenamt übernehmen
das ist schon klar grüne das weiß es
nicht es ist auch noch nicht entschieden
und ich glaube auch dass das alles
fragen sind das ist jetzt auch kein
spruch so also sagen immer erst die
inhalte dann soll sie miteinander labs
und dann wird darüber zu sprechen sein
haben sie lust nochmal minister zu sein
den nächsten tagen ist eine
außerordentlich interessante
herausforderung minister in deutschland
zu sein es gibt ganz viele die das als
eine herausforderung
empfinden oder zweifel werden wir sehen